imaginemos que tengo una moneda digamos
10 pesos o la denominación que ustedes
quieran y que voy a jugar unos volados
con mis amigos así que ahí tengo mi
moneda puede suponer que es una moneda
justa es decir no tienen ninguna especie
de truco y es igualmente posible obtener
un águila o un sol
yo voy a decir águila y sol ustedes
pueden pensar en cara o cruz o lo que se
les haga más fácil así que bien vamos a
hacer varios volados empecemos con un
solo volado y nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un águila cuál
es la probabilidad de obtener un águila
pues puede obtener dos eventos hay dos
eventos posibles obtengo águila obtengo
sol y de esos dos eventos sólo uno me
favorece solo me sirve si obtengo águila
así que la probabilidad de obtener
águila es un medio y qué hay de la
probabilidad de obtener un sol puedes
obtener un sol de nuevo tengo dos
eventos posibles y sólo uno favorecedor
así que la probabilidad de un sol es
igualmente 1
y noten que si sumo estas dos
probabilidades obtengo un medio más un
medio que es 1 y eso en general es
cierto siempre que sumen las
probabilidades de cualquiera de los
eventos si sumo todas las probabilidades
de todos los eventos posibles siempre
obtendré 1 el denominador siempre es la
cantidad de eventos posibles y el
numerador va a ir sumando hasta obtener
la cantidad de eventos posibles la
cantidad de ventas posibles de la
cantidad de eventos posibles claramente
es una así que bien aumentemos la
dificultad vamos a preguntarnos cuál es
la probabilidad de obtener un águila en
un primer volar y un águila en un
segundo volado
hay dos modos de pensar en esto el
primero sería contar todos los eventos
posibles que pueden ocurrir al hacer dos
volados podría pasar que obtenga águila
y luego aísla podría pasar que obtenga
águila y luego sol o podría pasar que
obtenga sol y luego águila o podría
pasar que obtenga sol y después sol así
que tengo cuatro eventos posibles cuatro
eventos posibles 7 ming denominador va a
ser 4 y de esos sólo uno me favorece
sólo quiero sacar águila y después
águila así que mi probabilidad de
obtener águila y después águilas sería
de un cuarto otro modo de pensar en esto
y de hecho esto es una idea muy
importante en probabilidad es considerar
lo que son eventos
independientes
independientes y eventos independientes
son esos que no tienen ninguna relación
entre ellos por ejemplo aquí el hecho de
que haya obtenido un águila en el primer
volado no tiene ninguna influencia sobre
el segundo volado a veces esto puede
causar un poco de confusión y llevar a
lo que se conoce como la falacia del
apostador que es que la gente cree que
si ha sacado muchas águilas en sucesión
entonces la probabilidad de obtener un
sol va en aumento pero eso no es el caso
no pierdan su dinero en un casino por
favor así que bien si considero estos
como eventos independientes que pasaría
pues resulta que como el primer volado
no influye para nada en el segundo esto
sería lo mismo que el producto de las
probabilidades el producto obtener un
águila en el primer volado y como el
primero es independiente del segundo
volado multiplicó por la probabilidad de
obtener una
así que para eventos independientes las
probabilidades se multiplican ahora bien
nosotros sabemos de acá arriba que esto
vale un medio la probabilidad de obtener
un águila en el primer volado puede
ponerle aquí un 1 del primer volado es
un medio y la probabilidad de obtener un
águila en el segundo volado también es
un medio así que esto un medio por un
medio es igual a un cuarto que es justo
lo que obtuvimos acá
bien vamos a subirle a una cerca de
dificultad de esto
vamos a considerar la probabilidad de
obtener un águila en el primer volado
cuando ya hemos usado mucho acta vamos a
considerar la probabilidad de obtener un
sol en el primer volado un águila en el
segundo volado y un sol en el tercer
volado de nuevo estos elementos
independientes ninguno de los volados
anteriores
afecta al volado siguiente así que esto
sería lo mismo que la probabilidad de
obtener un sol en el primer volado con
uno aquí por la probabilidad de obtener
un águila en el segundo volado por la
probabilidad de obtener un sol en el
tercer volado y realmente el hecho de
sacar una isla un sol es independiente
de el volado que se trate no importa si
es el primer o el segundo el tercero de
modo que esto
vale un medio esto vale un medio y esto
vale también un medio
si los multiplico tengo un medio por un
medio que es un cuarto por otro medio
sería un octavo
así que yo digo que la probabilidad de
obtener esta sucesión de eventos es un
octavo también podrían contar todos los
eventos vamos a enlistar todos los
eventos posibles para tres volados el
primero sería obtener un águila después
un águila y después otra águila podría
también pasarme que obtenga un águila en
el primero un águila en el segundo y un
sol en el tercero después podría pasarme
que obtengo un águila en el primero un
sol en el segundo y un águila en el
tercero o también podría pasarme a
obtener un águila luego un sol y después
otro sable
también podría pasarme a obtener un sol
después son aguilar y después otra
águila también podría pasarme obtener un
sol después otra águila y después un sol
o podría pasarme obtener un sol después
otro sol y después un águila o podría
pasarme obtener un sol en absolutamente
todos los intentos así que tuve 12345678
eventos posibles ocho eventos posibles y
de esos cuales me favorecen cuales
satisfacen muy restricción pues en
realidad sólo éste tiene el orden
correcto son águila sol así que tengo un
evento favorable entre ocho eventos
posibles la probabilidad de nuevo es un
octavo